Modeling cameras in MATLAB
Let’s demonstrate some of these principles
in MATLAB. I’m going to create a point in
the world and it’s going to be at coordinate
0.2 meters in the X direction 0.3 meters in
the Y direction and it’s going to be 5 meters
in Z direction. Now Z is the direction along
the axis of a camera we call the optical axis
of the camera. This is a relatively small
object five meters away from the camera and
a world point is always a column vector so
there it is.
Now I’m going to create a camera object
in fact a central camera object which does
the particular projection that we just learned
about and it’s got a focal length of eight
millimetres.
So here we created the workspace now a central
camera projection object. This object has
got quite a lot of methods and we’ll have
a look at some of those. But first thing I’m
going to do is to use this camera object and
I’m going to project my world point capital
P to the image plane, what you see here is that we have got some very small numbers.
These numbers are less than half a millimetre.
We've taken our view of the world and we've
made it much, much smaller and projected it
onto the image plane. This is where the piece
of film would be or this is where the digital
camera chip would be. In this projection there’s
no notion of pixels we've just taken image
in the world and it’s described in terms
of size and its distance in units of meters. We've projected it to the image plane and
this is talking about the size of the image
also in units of meters; a very small number of meters.
Now let’s turn this into a digital camera
let’s introduce the notion of pixels. We’re
going to create a new camera object. Basically
recycle this line and we will tell it that
the pixels are ten microns on a side so the
pixels are square ten microns wide ten microns
high. And their image plane has got a resolution
of one thousand and twenty four square. This
is a mega pixel camera.
Now if we look at the parameters of our camera
object we see here we can see the focal length.
Here we can see the size of pixels, the number
of pixels, 1024 x 1024 exactly what we entered
on the command line. And this parameter the
principle point which is where the optical
axis pierces the image plane is smacked in
the middle at coordinate 512, 512.
Now that I have my digital camera object,
we can re do that projection that we had before
project to world point P and this now is the
coordinate of that point in units of pixels.
Another method of the camera object is to
actually plot these on a graphical image plane
and here we can see where that world point
has been projected to on the digital cameras
image plane. So now the methods we can look
at the cameras intrinsic parameters. Now this
is the intrinsic parameter matrix; this is
the overall camera projection matrix. We can
pass an additional option into the project
function.
First argument again is our world point and
now I’m going to shift the camera a little
bit. Now I’m going to tell it to shift the
camera 0.1 meters in the X direction given
the camera’s coordinate frame that’s a
shift of 0.1 meters to the right. Not going
to move it in the Y or in the Z directions
so now what we see is that the projection
is different. And we would expect that, we
see that the U coordinate has been reduced
from 544 to 528 and that’s what we would
expect if we move the camera to the right
we would expect the image plane coordinate
to move a bit to the left.
Instead of translating the camera we could
rotate the camera so we can rotate the camera
around the Y axis. Now the Y axis points downwards
so if I do this rotation of 0.1 radians around
the Y axis that’s essentially rotating the
camera towards the right and if we do that
here’s the projection again and as we would
expect if I rotate the camera a bit towards
the right the pixel in the image will move
a bit towards the left on the image plane.
Let’s consider a more complex example, one
where there are multiple points in the world.
To create multiple points in a grid pattern
now I’m going to use the toolbox function
mkgrid and I want a 2x2 grid and the points
spaced on 0.2 metre centers and I want the
center of the grid to be at a coordinate 1,
2, 0. So this is a grid in the XY plane, the
center of the grid is offset 1 metre in the
X direction and 2 metres in the Y direction
and all the points have got a Z coordinate
of zero.
So here are the set of points that I have
just created in order to view these four points
which lie on a ground plane I’m going to
create a new camera. It’s a central projection
model camera again. I’m going to set default
camera parameters so this is default values
for focal length image plane size and pixel
size. I’m going to explicitly give the pose
of the camera so our four points are lying
on the ground plane so in order for my camera
to be able to see them it needs to be somewhere
up high looking down so the first thing that
I’m going to do is to place the camera 4
metres above the ground. So this is a translation
of 4 metres along the positive Z axis and
then I’m going to rotate it around the Z
axis by Pi on three radians and then I’m
going to rotate the camera around the Y axis
so it points down at the ground.
So just rotate it around the Y axis by pi
radians. Bare with me I’ll work this example
out and these numbers should give something
like the right result.
First thing we’re going to do is to project
those 4 world points onto the camera’s image
plane and here we have the coordinates of
those points. So they clearly lay within the
field of view and we can actually have a look
at those four points. And we can plot those
and that’s what the image plane looks like.
So they’re just in the edge of the field
of view of our camera, which is looking down.
Now let’s try and get a 3D understanding
of what’s going on here so I’m going to
create a new figure. I’m going to call it
figure two and another method on the camera
object we just created is called plot camera.
What that does it to render it’s a 3D model
of a camera into a graphic and the other thing
that I’m going to do is to add to these
graphic the 4 world points given my capital
P I’m going to render them as the little
spheres with a radius of 0.5 meters each so
created this little scene, turn the grid on
to make it a bit easier to see.
If I turn on my 3D rotation tool I can spin
this around. Here we can see what it looks
like, here are the four points on the ground
plane now then I created using the grid function.
And up the top we can see the camera and we
can see the axis of the camera. Camera is
a little bit small. We can zoom in and have
a look at the camera there is it, there we
can see its x, y and z axis, zoom in a little
bit more perhaps and we can see there, it
looks a little bit like a camera. It’s a
box with a cylinder on the front. These are
just the few examples of the many things that
you can do using the camera classes within
the toolbox.